if you're looking forward to ukulele
next year then I've got a bunch of news
for you I'm Tony and this is your
platforming game spot news update
developer play tonic released a new
trailer showing off the capital casino
world you can see a few new moves and
enemies in the footage but that's not
all the trailer ends with the game's
release date April 11th 2017
you can now pre-order the game virtually
and in store and this will get you
instant access to the game's toy box a
spoiler free area meant to show off the
game's mechanics play tonic is also
looking into ways for Kickstarter
backers to upgrade their pledges to
physical copies ukulele is headed to ps4
Xbox one and PC the Wii U version has
unfortunately been cancelled but play
tonic will offer a free exchange for
another version of game or an upgrade to
the planned Nintendo switch version the
game isn't finalized for that console
just yet
but play Tomic does want it to happen
fingers crossed to keep up with all the
latest on ukulele you're already in the
right place
you